I love people you know
um when covet happened and a lot of
people went to tick tock just to sort of
let off steam I guess I just loved how
much creativity there is people are
really funny and smart you know like
when I get down on anything I'm I'm
reminded of just how great people are
and one of the great things about living
in a post-lockdown world is I'm getting
to meet people again and I'm inspired by
people I'm inspired by the conversations
I think one of the greatest attributes
any one of us can have is the
realization that we know a tiny tiny
tiny little bit and no matter how much
we know we don't know so much more and I
love hearing the ideas of other people
and I love the intellectual banter and
advancing ideas so yeah
people are my thing